how dangerous is debt it causes people
to lose their homes and States to go to
war debt can be a matter of life or
death
at first debt just exists on paper
anyone taking out a bank loan signs a
contract promising to return a borrowed
some plus interest but if you default on
your mortgage for instance the bank will
repossess your home borrowing to pay for
a car a home or a holiday is especially
risky you're safer for example if you
make money you've borrowed work for you
by taking out say a mortgage on a
property you then rent out an entire
financial industry has been built around
buying or selling debt securities
speculators even place bets on whether
entire countries are in danger of going
bankrupt nations whose debts exceed
their entire economic output measured in
terms of gross domestic product are
viewed as high-risk national public debt
in the eurozone States is supposed to
remain under 60 percent of GDP but in
many countries it exceeds that which
erodes investor confidence investors and
lenders respond by demanding higher
interest rates due to the increased risk
of default and a state in crisis
constantly needs new loans to refinance
the old ones before long no one wants to
lend any more money to debtor nations
like Greece or Italy and bankruptcy
looms but states need the money to
kickstart their economies by building
roads and schools for example and
investing in the future that helps
create jobs increases tax revenue and
ultimately could bring a state back into
the black so debts can have a positive
effect as long as they can be repaid
but gross debt levels worldwide have
more than doubled since the turn of the
century governments firms and households
now owe a grand total of around 280
trillion euros that's three times
greater than global GDP so who is going
to pay it back